um congrats you got the new EP out yes
thank you uh it's called after the
butterflies now what does that mean does
that mean like once things get a little
toxic in a relationship cuz then there's
the butterfly stage I always say you get
in a relationship things are beautiful
and then you know what happens when the
butterflies go away I wouldn't call it
toxic I don't think it's toxic sometimes
just becomes like you know I mean real
realistic like realistically people are
not going to be like in love well super
duper in love every single day forever
like of course that happens like in the
beginning where you see the kind of girl
I am like I see no wrong in the
beginning like you can't do no wrong the
honeymoon stage yes basically after the
honeymoon stage um and when the rosec
colored glasses come off and it's like
okay yeah there's things I actually
don't like about you and like things
that he don't like about me and and
disagreements and like possibility of a
breakup you know like no yeah like once
you first start dating somebody you'll
put all of the like if you're really
into somebody you all the stuff that
everything is you just put to the side I
even love the flaws like I love this
like in the beginning I love the things
that I shouldn't so let me ask you this
cuz I feel like it's unfair of women to
like love something about somebody or
even even men too cuz this happens a lot
like I have friends of mine who like my
wife used to be a dancer so I I didn't
never gave a [__] still don't give a
[__] but I have homies of mine who like
like you'll fall like you'll fall for
somebody be like and fall for them in a
certain line of work or for who they are
at a certain time and then hold that
against them later mhm have you ever
done that are you guilty of that no um
wait hold on I maybe I spoke too quick
like you like some of the flaws like you
embrace the flaws initially but
eventually you're like man I don't like
you cuz this what it's like well you
like you knew that you knew what it was
when you got that have years something
that you like went into knowing it was
there you didn't mind it and then all of
a sudden like all of a sudden it's a
thing yeah um H I don't know why my
voice just crack like that but
um what could I say maybe a sometimes
girls I won't say like this is like
specifically to me but sometimes girls
love
that that little like telling you what
to do kind of thing when a guy's like no
you ain't don't wear this or don't do
that and like it's like oh it's so cute
like he don't want me to cares but yeah
like or he's you know it's cute he's a
little but then after a while um it
becomes controlling and it becomes like
okay annoying like you're not my dad
yeah um I do believe you should have a
certain respect though for the man that
you're with as he should have for you
but of course I think that's like a big
sign of like uh insecurity though for
for a male yeah what to kind of tell you
not to wear yeah or like that or I also
feel like I feel like dudes like will
have a a real
like inclination to like try to keep
women like in in yeah or in their little
like grasp you know what I'm saying as a
as opposed to like like you know I feel
like a lot of guys don't want to lose
they want to keep the girl their girl to
themselves yeah and it's like hey man
like I mean if you really locked in with
that girl you ain't going to lose her
that's what I'm saying I remember I
wasn't able to wear uh a bathing suit in
my last relationship um a bathing suit
Yeah well yeah I had to like put shorts
over my even if it was a one piece I
couldn't do it I couldn't wear a bathing
suit oh my God yeah so like um and it
was just I don't know it was it was
weird but um and like we're like so I
grew up in a church we were both
Christian but he said he appreciated how
like
Muslims you know how the wives were
always covered and like red flag um and
I you know to me it was just like that
was that was really weird I did not like
that at all the my current relationship
he like don't tell me anything about
what well this is the thing like it's a
bathing suit like you can't help the way
you look in a bathing suit like my booty
I didn't even have a BBL then like my my
booty was like it was a regular booty
right so I don't even understand why but
like that's [__] crazy was a regular
butt damn so like is that was that kind
of like a a reason for you to like okay
I I got to get out of this thing oh no
it was way more things and that like
that was just a you know but I don't
even want to like hone in all that I
just thought since we were talking about
yeah yeah no that's wild though yeah
dude's got to stop being that way man
especially if you got a beautiful woman
it's like hey man it doesn't matter if
you're a mom it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter like a woman should be
able to like wear what she wants of
course Kiki Palmer's baby daddy is
[__] he's a s that dude is tripping
bro I'm like you got mad cuz your girl
went out with her homies in Vegas she
had a Vegas outfit on she's a she just
had a baby this is a great night out for
her MH Usher happened to sing to her I
just don't think that it you know
has to be um u a limit on I mean okay I
will say this like just we're all
different everyone's different right I I
have worn some things that were like
revealing um but not like super duper
revealing like where I'm just out here
naked but like that's to each his own
yeah I mean also you know it's a you're
an artist yeah I mean what that mean I
mean that like as an artist like you're
a beautiful woman who I'm sure you know
like a part of your uh your brand is how
you're also a beautiful woman thank you
yeah so yeah shout out to your current
guy who feels like he's got it figured
out huh thank you I guess thanks on his
behalf uh anyway yo so um so once once
you get past the butterflies how do you
make the relationship work oh that's a
good question um I feel like um a lot of
people don't believe in this but therapy
therapy is really good um because it's
good to have like a non-biased coupl
therapy couples therapy is great and the
individual therapy because I I do feel
like a lot of reasons why relationships
don't work out is because individually
like we haven't like healed our own
traumas so like something that the your
partner could do could trigger something
from like uh that you didn't even know
you like like yeah like make yeah and
it's like a root behind it like it could
be nothing even super huge about it but
like something really triggered
something you went through like I know I
have triggers and traumas from like just
people telling me what to do and people
controlling me and so like even if in
the past I've gotten mad like if he's
tried to give me
some advice and it maybe was like a
little it was just little too sometimes
the truth be hurting and it like
triggers something from the past yeah
when really he was just trying to look
out for my best interest so I mean
that's just an example I feel like
therapy couples therapy regular therapy
and just like keeping it spicy I feel
like um when you stay in the house and
you're just especially if you live with
a person like if y'all are trapped in
four walls oh yeah and you just do the
same thing every day especially if you
got kids like y'all need to get out the
house and do new things like things that
y'all haven't done together even if it's
in the same city or go on vacation
whatever but like um make new memories
always cuz if you don't have nothing to
talk about everything just becomes like
super Bland no it's definitely hard
especially when you have kids and you're
always home the kids do a number I got
two kids so I me tooo so what you got
girls or boys two boys I got two boys
too yeah I my one of my kids just turned
18 so I have like a little man that
lives in my house literally he could go
buy cigarettes right now oh wow how old
are your kids um they're eight and four
um so you have like a eight-year-old is
like a little man too kind yeah he's
about to be nine in February my he's
grown youngest is about to be five in
January so yeah he he he what's he into
is he into like YouTubers or yeah he
wants to be that's what he grew up on
he's he wants to be a streamer yep yeah
CJ wants to be a streamer he already has
a PC I have a 10-year-old that's like
all that they're into these YouTubers
and these like influencers he's watching
the reaction Chanel beast and reaction
channels and they be on the reals or or
the shorts the YouTube shorts are crazy
it's like I can't even keep up like
sometimes he'll be scrolling through and
I'll like hear some stuff I he should
and I'm like turn that off every day
every single day my K stop it he'll be
sitting and having breakfast and he
throws on YouTube on the big TV but he
puts the shorts on and he'll just hit
next on all this and I'm like bro they
love the shorts it's crazy this is this
is the generation of children that we
both have it's scary we'll see what they
grow up to end up being well I'm I'm
going keep praying over mine cuz uh for
sure